let's return now to our top story the
acquittal of a man
convicted in the murder of the wall
street journal reporter daniel
pearl by pakistan's top court let's go
live to our correspondent kamar haider
in islamabad
developments taking place this morning
talk us through the details of what
pakistan's supreme court has announced
this morning
well first of all it's important to
understand that the send government
where the case was being heard initially
and where the supreme court of the sindh
province
had first acquitted omar sheikh last
year
had filed the sin government had filed
of a petition
in the supreme court along with daniel
pearl's family
against that acquittal however the
supreme court decided
to uphold the acquittal of that
particular court which is the send high
court
and that of course is has sent
shockwaves his law their family lawyer
has said that omar sheikh has indeed
admitted in a
written note that he had a minor role
in the murder of the wall street
journalist daniel
pearl what that role was is not certain
but the court of of course upholding the
acquittal
which was earlier announced by the
sinned high court
kamal this was a huge story at the time
with global repercussions give us a bit
more background on how we got to this
point
well this dates back to 2002 the uh
journalist for wall street journal the
bureau chief daniel pearl
was in the city of karachi where he met
umar sheikh and of course uh uh
it was at that sade he was at that time
lowered into a trap which then led to
his beheading
and he was put in a shallow grave after
that
his body was discovered he was arrested
omar was arrested and sentenced by an
anti-terrorist court to death
uh of course after that the case went on
for several years
he was on death row along with other
accomplices
however last year the dissent high court
decided to acquit him
and the other accomplices as well that
then was challenged here in pakistan
supreme court but it was a huge case
it was a high-profile journalist that
sent shockwaves around the journalistic
world as well
and to a degree also harmed relations
uh with washington because last year the
american administration the outgoing
administration
of trump had also voiced his displeasure
over the acquittal of this key suspect
many thanks for that kamal haider there
for us in islamabad